welcome back to las vegas now we are
focusing on our health
and wellness for this wellness wednesday
oh it's thursday
oh my gosh this was there yesterday it's
not it's not wednesday we're going to
call this
together thursday all right with the
help of southwest medical a doctor
joining me to discuss the importance of
health care for our local seniors here's
our conversation
we usually talk about health care for
older adults so let's talk about
what are the special needs for them
right now during this time it's
especially important to keep them safe
and healthy
as we get older you know our bodies
needs change
and diet and exercise become even more
important as we get older
so things such as endurance strength
balance and flexibility are really
important for staying
healthy as we get older it definitely um
also helps to reduce the risk for falls
one important thing to keep in mind is
to be physically active every day what
are some of those activities
what are some good ideas for people to
stay active mentally and physically
yeah great question so actually we have
um
our optimum care community centers which
do offer a whole wide range of variety
activities for our seniors um there are
classes
for you know there's dance classes
there's exercise classes
they also do screening tests there for
example they can do a bone density test
to see how strong your bones are
and whether you need some sort of
treatment to get them stronger
they do circulation tests and it's also
a good place for them to make friends
which then helps to you know reduce
isolation um
and then also helps to ward up
depression
absolutely and i know i love this about
the community centers that
you don't have to be a healthcare member
to actually join it or use it right
absolutely you do not have to be a
healthcare member you can certainly go
in there
but if you are a healthcare member then
those
things such as those testing such as the
bone density
circulation nerve testing discussing
your prescriptions
you can get all those done there as well
and i heard
you guys actually accept original
medicare now absolutely yes that's very
exciting for us we
are accepting original medicare and we
still accept all of um
the same medicare advantage programs
that we did before
but yes we're really excited about
accepting the original medicare patients
beautiful and let's go down the list of
those non-sports related activities that
older girls can get into
i know you mentioned well dancing
yes so dancing
you know window shopping i know they're
here in vegas at least we do have some
outdoor space
malls um now that it's a little cooler
it's
some place to you know go walk and do
window shopping
gardening um dancing at home with your
grandkids
what are those next steps that people
should take you know after they listen
to this segment
what should they do talk to your doctor
about
you know your medications including any
over-the-counter supplements you're
taking
the reason that is important because
sometimes the over-the-counter
supplements can interact with the
prescription medication
so next time you go to see your provider
take
all your medications with you including
the supplements with you so that you
know we can have an
accurate list in your chart
thank you dr carr southwest medical has
locations across southern nevada just
call them at
702-877-5199
dot com kendall